hello freak [ __ ] but but he got even
bigger after that yeah but you're a
matter yeah yeah I I here soon she was
so hot but she's still hot yeah 17 my
favorite is her in that Chuck Norris
what do you call it the total gym oh
that's right when they would do the
little dude I I would watch that info
I love infomercials I watch them late at
night and that was my favorite
infomercial and then they remade it oh
yeah and I didn't like it as much as the
original that's how much I watched
because the original was so good because
Chuck Norris was like let's just [ __ ]
get through this and Christie Brinkley
was doing it really well
but it was just so funny to see Chuck
Norrises face during that and then read
did and he figured it out he figured I
had to do a little better or nothing
like that dude I met Chuck Norris I met
him a couple times this was a proudest
moment of my life and Chuck Norris knew
who I was
oh I heard you know for real neat and
Chuck Norris he comes gives you a big
hug oh yeah holy [ __ ] Chuck Norris what
I know I am just the UFC I'm sure you
know this is not that long ago no oh wow
my first met him I think maybe was 10
years ago okay not 2007 and I met him
again I think about two years ago I met
him again that's funny I always I was
think about guys like that that were
like big that got big off of like
martial arts yeah in the 80s and 90s and
then the UFC came along and like kind of
made those martial arts in a fighting
sense obsolete right you know like if
they would be that bit I guess that's
not going to happen anymore really I
mean I don't know it is I know what
you're saying but like kung fu movies
are obviously more beautiful than what's
that movie that Carolyn did the played
Ewan what was that yeah warrior yeah
yeah well the thing about Chuck Norris
though is that he stayed current Chuck
Norris is a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu oh yes yeah he's legit under
the Machado's and on top of that at
school he was a world champion kickboxer
right yeah no there Norris was like he
could grapple at a very high level and
he can probably no world champion
striker Chuck Norris is about as legit
as any like movie character tough guy
about as legit as they've ever been
especially a guy who went on to do all
these great movies like Bruce Lee was a
phenomenal martial artist and a
brilliant guy in terms of like how he
put things together but as far as like
actual competition
Chuck Norris is the man
he was he was the guy but when I was a
kid dude like Chuck Norris movies are
the reason why I got into martial arts
really dude he was huge jeans on with a
special caution gene said a special
crotch cut in the jeans like a [ __ ]
psycho their cowboy boots on I saw that
I found out about action jeans and late
in life and I was like that was a
[ __ ] thing
dude I basically wear them I mean I with
what I wear now is more ridiculous than
Chuck Norrises actually yeah well the
times have changed I mean I have jog
jeans which is like [ __ ] their
stretch so I'm talking about yeah that's
what I'm wearing right you didn't how
much more common way more comfortable
yeah these were [ __ ] like when you
had one kick behind your legs when we
would get pants if I got pants I always
got pants that were too big for me just
like you kick people oh I want to make
sure I take people just a case should
never happen to em I died I never
happened ever
[Applause]
[Music]